ich bin nicht mehr so wie früher
verstehen sie und da wo wir vielleicht
von früher kennt da der versager da sind
sie nicht verstehen aber ich finde
möchte organe so sei und das ist
positive kann ein mensch der die
öffentlichkeit als hochstapler und
scheint das licht geführt hat plötzlich
ein anderer sein
und welche rolle spielt er wenn er
vorgibt keine rolle zu spielen
von solcherlei fragen handelt diese
geschichte
[Musik]
meine erinnerungen an den mann sind noch
frisch vor fünf jahren reiste volker
eckel als falscher scheint durch die
schweiz mit foto kopierten auszügen von
erfundenen bankkonten gaukelte er
reichtum und wichtigkeit von 2009
gelangte er als hochstapler in die
schlagzeilen weil er für 300 millionen
franken die schuldengeplagten jaspers
kaufen wollte das erstaunlichste an der
geschichte ist und bleibt dass sich
intelligente menschen von einem haben
blenden lassen
der einfachste sätze nicht fehlerfrei
schreiben konnte egal ob er schrieb er
sah in london und treffe da seinen
bruder doktor hassan hussein oder indem
er vorgab dass er sein gedächtnis
verloren habe nur als seine assistentin
schreiben ließ er sei gestorben
triebes auf die spitze guten morgen herr
eckel ist heute nacht ums leben gekommen
er hat sie als freund angesehen mit
freundlichen grüßen
dass volker eckel auch im herbst 2014
noch lebt davon ging ich aus als ich
mich auf machte ihn im schwarzwald zu
besuchen
fünf jahrzehnte ja immer behauptet dass
jeder sohn von saddam hussein
bin gespannt
über volker eckel hatte vor fünf jahren
die halbe schweiz gelacht am lautesten
jene die ihm kurz zuvor noch auf den
leim gekrochen waren schon deshalb fand
ich sollte er gelegenheit erhalten sich
zur damaligen situation zu äußern
immerhin hat er seit damals über zwei
jahre im gefängnis verbracht und
außerdem mit seiner ehemaligen
assistentin eine familie gegründet
was sie mir als erstes gesagt haben ich
weiß es nicht genau das ist dann helfe
ich habe sie als erstes gefragt sind sie
froh sind habe ich glaube sagt ja folge
habe gesagt
beides um zu erfahren wie eckel die
dinge heute sieht schauen wir gemeinsam
die reportage über unsere letzte
begegnung an
volker eckel ist 44 jahre erst die
wohnung geplant
so steht in den papieren doch solche
ecke sagt er sei auch prinz mohammed
teilweise zu künftiges staatsoberhaupt
von saudi arabien schwerer jedem der mit
ihm ins geschäft kommt verspricht er
viel geld fast wie immer ich weiß ist
mit korrekter weise aktuell weise was
ist richtig alles bringt muss ist ja
ich fahre mit der realität ich habe es
auch nicht steuern können
und heute teilweise muss ich selber den
kopf schütteln und denken sie mir auf
jeden fall stehe aber dazu aber ich kann
es nicht rückgängig machen leider leider
etwas im kanton thurgau
in diesem haus wohnt langjährige
gemeinderätin
das verblüffende an apples märchen war
schon vor fünf jahren wie er angesehene
leute für sich gewinnen konnte und eine
gemeinderätin bot er einen fantastischen
arbeitsvertrag an das gehalt 76 1923
fanden monat dazu aus dem fahrzeug ein
bmw unter der leser haben sie
verständnis für die vier jahre sie da
eingewilligt hat heute die jetzt gerade
den vertrag ein schaurig jeder zustimmt
wird wenn er das hört sich jetzt gemein
vielleicht ein wenn alle tassen im
schrank hat stimmte nicht zu
ja aber wenn der geldgierige stimmen
dazu er mag es sich ein bisschen
einfacher machen mit seinem blick zurück
und bestimmt lässt sich die eigene hier
nicht mit jener der anderen
entschuldigen doch ist es eine tatsache
dass er seinen luftschlössern nicht
alleine baute viele halfen ihm dabei
als wollten sie nicht sehen dass hinter
dem schwebenden scheich ein gewöhnlicher
hilfsarbeiter ohne festes einkommen
steckte
ich habe davor die bewilligung schon
gehabt ja und so haben die stimmen
fragen wie sind sie darauf waren
wirklich wird sie jetzt beinahe blöd an
einem tisch kommt mir in der wette
abgeschlossen und ich war ja wieder
unangreifbar
ja ja ja war mit meiner leute zusammen
kommt dass er in den drei welt war dass
ich sagte ich will jetzt die c
bewilligung innerhalb von einer woche
hatte und die absicht und dadurch will
ich mal sagen ist auch hat keiner
gefragt wie er es geschafft daraus
gemacht dadurch bin ich auch glaubhaft
als zeitraums holen als der damalige
thurgauer finanzdirektor betonte schon
vor fünf jahren stets vorschriftsgemäß
gehandelt zu haben
also indem sie nicht völlig
gesetzeskonform ablauf ist denkbar dass
nicht dann halt den pc noch schneller
schafft der kanton vertrag jetzt schon
die aussicht auf dem geld ja leider so
einfach gute frage es wird mir einfach
gemacht man hat immer gesagt mit dem
steuerbeamte hat mich getroffen hat und
die gastgeber war und dann hat man im
betrag gesprochen wie ich heute weiss 5
millionen und dann hat man sich darauf
gebe und dann war das geregelt so
einfach so einfach war das
innerhalb von fünf minuten war das über
den tisch die ing interesse gehabt mich
bin in der schweiz zu habe und in auggen
in der pankower kanton thurgau weil der
verhandlung wo ich gehabt hat bevorteilt
würde bin ist es auch zur sprache kommen
und da hatten polizei haben die
schweizer haben da wo es gesagt wo er
ermittelt hat ist ja leider auf die ping
kommen dass jeder gesagt hat einen
thurgauer jetzt ja erlaubt sein
wir haben den herrn eckel wollen wir
behalten hier in der schweiz
da wollen wir nicht
glos habe der richter hat ja auch
gefragt ob das so war der krebs maße so
groß da geht es nicht wenn sie es
wirklich wissen sollten ja sogar
angeboten worden aber auch kein hehl
machen wenn ich jede vorgreifen
deutschland habe ich ein prozess gehabt
daher kommt sogar zugesichert man hat
mich gefragt ob er privatunterricht
schreiben sollen an die
staatsanwaltschaft nahm ich gesagt um
gottes wille herr koch sind lassen sie
sind es lieb gemeint bestimmt aber muss
ich wieder was zahl um korruption
naja so damals ahnen dass da alles
entschieden so krise werden vor allem
deshalb will behinderte riesen lotto es
ist nicht ein franke kloster also geld
zeit siemens gestellt und den beamten
sondern sie statt sechs oder mehr licht
ein sagen kann jedoch hin und da darf
man das ganze geschichte zurück wie es
war das erreicht ja nur dazu einfach
darauf hat sich nichts zu schulden
kommen lassen absolut gut wie kamen sie
dazu das zu behaupten
ich habe ja irgendwas behaupten müssen
sonst wären damit glaubhaft krise kann
und dass wir uns also absolut bei ihm
auf jeden fall da tut mir wirklich leid
dass er da so von mir ins falsche licht
rücken oder ist das etwa bei dem motiv
leitplanke
doch war es genau der moment in dem der
scheich an glaubwürdigkeit gewonnen und
gleichzeitig an bodenhaftung verlor
jetzt mit der politischen absolution war
ihm keine behauptung mehr zu absurd
wurde etwas in frage gestellt so legte
er noch einen oben drauf so markant sind
auf senior gab ich hatte einen
unheimlichen über zügig kraft und lud
worüber 64
die münze hand die trümmer der
mannschaft gespürt wie sie sich für
europa begeistern
und dann bin ich daraus entstanden und
dann war es so man hat mich wenn es in
arabischer ist so ein kind unehelich
verstehen sie auf die welt bringt und
die familie ist dagegen ja das oberhaupt
davor könig fahd das erfahren hätte mich
töten müssen
ach ja es ist so nach dem saudischen
gesetzt und der jetzige könig
die geschichte doch nicht einfach so
beim zubettgehen kurz einen kaffee
trinken sollten wie kamen sie darauf 00
plan wirklich nicht
darf ich mir erlauben zu sagen sie haben
nicht eine große ähnlichkeit mit gott
seid ein album mit meiner mutter absolut
schon absolut klasse glaubt die rolle ja
sonst hätte sein leben kenne diese rolle
ja oder mich nach hause verkaufen wenn
ich das jetzt nicht glaubt was ich da so
ein quatsch erzählt habe
dann hätte das internet verkaufen oder
andere ja also in dem man sich gar nicht
bewusst angelogen eigentlich nicht weil
ich ja das geglaubt habe selber hat
ihnen ihr vater das nie um genau die
richtige erfahrung
ja ich sage er hat serie vorschuss
bereits rechte tür zuzuschlagen und zu
sagen zu mir gesagt ich will nie wieder
was mit ihr zu tun haben
ja aber er hat es gott sei dank nicht
nach ok meine brüder die redet mit mir
ihr habt keinen kontakt aber naja wenn
die meinen es ist okay dann muss ich
damit zurecht kommen
aber mein vater hat man die hand
gereicht und ich eben haben ihn schuldig
und mir redet miteinander und service
okay damals lud eckel seine mitarbeiter
nach frauenfeld zur weiterbildung ein
hier sollten sie arabische benimm regeln
kennen lernen
die viel unterwegs sind und ob sie
[Musik]
einfach so schön so quillt und der name
spiele spiele wie man aber ist 23 dafür
aber sie zweite wir haben dafür zu
europa traten da war am telefon nicht um
familie und was wird schnell wartet sehr
schwachen familien und geschafft aber
schon machen
das ist ausdrücklich zeigt wurde das
perfekt zusammen
ich glaube mir war ein ganz gutes gerüst
sage man mit leuten wohl jeder gierig
war ob sich jetzt war oder die täter
hingestellt wir waren alle und gefräst
aufsagen und ja dann sieht man was draus
wird immer zu gierig wird ohne plan habe
er gehandelt
aber mit dem sicheren instinkt dafür
dass im chronisch defizitären
fußballgeschäft jeder aufmerksamkeit
erhält der das große geld verspricht
natürlich sich im mikrokosmos von der
gesellschaft und marie bis zum größeren
betrügen der bis zum gewissen
große schwarz oder weiß die
boulevardzeitungen stürzten sich mit
hochgenuss auf eckel und dieser gefiel
sich in der rolle des geheimnisvollen
investors ich habe da improvisieren
müssen von einer rolle in die andere und
es war mal ehrlich hätte sie wenn zu
ihnen jemand sagt ich bin seit am so
lange wochen erstmal hinterkopf fordern
ein arabisches sieht aber scheinbar die
anderen glauben es ist faszinierend wie
bisher die ballkontrolle und man hatte
die werbungen über milliarden verfügt
noch alles investieren und sich alles
leisten und die größte luftschlösser am
boden das ist schön wenn man das ja
sie wollte so noch am funktionieren dass
man vertraut realität darüber gab es ist
immer schlimmer potter dass ich auch mal
gesagt habe mir selber mein gefährte
festgenommen das ist vorbei es soweit
fragen der schweiz am ende auch und wir
das wirklich es war überfroh bus vorbei
war wirklich am zweiten mai 2012
verurteilte das landgericht rottweil den
damals 46 jährigen enkel zu einer
freiheitsstrafe von dreieinhalb jahren
haben sie gebüßt dafür ja auch der 20
monate mehr als das ich habe jetzt so
gebot von meiner tochter könne
hosenfeld komisch die kleine ja und das
ist mir wünsche dass niemand wenn er zur
geburt geht auf ja und dann auch zwei
herz-op seine krebs op im haft hier
glaubt habe genug gebüßt schoss ein
schlechtes gewissen heute nein ich habe
meine strafe ab guckt und ich habe nie
jemand benötigt dazu das muss immer
sagen und in dem wird nie jemand der
finger geführt du musst da
unterschreiben
meine strafe auf prüfen das gericht
hatte eckel für schuldig befunden in
fünf fällen gewerbsmäßig betrug begangen
zu haben allerdings anerkannte der
richter beim angeklagten eine
gesundheitlich bedingte verminderte
steuerungsfähigkeit eckel hatte
glaubhaft machen können er habe nicht
mehr zwischen seiner waren und der
erfundenen lebensgeschichte
unterscheiden können
diese persönlichkeitsstörung wirkte sich
strafmildernd aus wovon leben sie im
moment ganz einfach in deutschland gilt
sich als mittellos da stehe ich dazu und
schäme mich dafür auch überhaupt nicht
aber ich habe nie behauptet dass ich
habe nie behauptet dass das geld mehr
gehört ja und dann kann ich doch in der
königlichen hof liegt haben und da kann
ich ja nicht sagen
das geld gehört mir das märchen vom
vielen geld
es ist auch die geschichte von menschen
die volker eckel haben wollten weil sie
gerne wichtiger größer und reicher
gewesen wären ja sonst richtig gesagt ja
ich wollte fragen
diese diese gelte die geflossen sind ja
mit denen haben sie zu der zeit ihre
rechnungen bezahlt richtig und habe aber
auch immer meine leute wo richtig gehabt
haben gelder zu urlaub finanzieren oder
wovon leben sie heute hartz iv bekommen
sie genügend geld um zu leben
es reicht also erst mal glücklich sein
reich sind sie nicht nein möchte auch
gern mal eben reich das einmal meine
frau meine kinder am tisch reichtum klug
in haft erkrankte apple an krebs nach
geglückter operation und überstandener
therapie genießt er heute die zeit mit
seiner familie sanierer und sarah heißen
die beiden kinder die er gemeinsam mit
sabine tig gehabt dazu kommen sabines
kinder manuel und lisa marie aus einer
früheren ehe
zurückschauen mag die familie nur ungern
den augenblick als sabine vor gericht
die wahrheit über ihren mann erfuhr
werde sie aber nie vergessen ich mich so
toll wenn man zwei gesichter oder zwei
menschen in einer sagen bei mir so bei
anderen so man kann schon sagen er war
zwei personen ein
er hat praktisch von einer sekunde auf
jahre nicht schreiben können
dabei hat er bei mir war aber was gibt
ihnen heute die echtheit dass es nicht
wieder eine rolle wenn auch eine schöne
die kinder geben mir die gewissheit
unterhalb von meiner frau absolut ja
und das gibt es natürlich 100 prozent
sicherheit weil ich bin so was rutschen
weil meine frau war weg und die kinder
und das ist es nicht wert
absolut nicht dann lieber auf vieles
verzichten
mit kleinigkeiten zufrieden sei und auch
akzeptieren dass man kein reicher mann
ist das ist wichtig
wie schade jeder zukunft aus die nerven
nähere zukunft ich hoffe dass jetzt
soweit gesund bleibt das ist jetzt so
blau dass der krebs zurück konnten sich
mal zurückkommt das ist auch mitspielt
beruflich war schauen dass ich wieder
meinen beruf einsteigen könnte und er
macht den hausmann das andere nicht
geben aber ein scheich haben sie nie
geworden
ich glaube das würde ich einen neo aus
dem kopf gegen volker eckel kam einst
als jüngstes von fünf kindern zur welt
aufmerksamkeit erhielt er immer dann
wenn er vorgab etwas ausgefressen zu
haben
so lernte er die scheinwelt der
wirklichkeit vorzuziehen wenn ihre
kinder irgendwann ja älter sind und da
sie zu kommen und fragen papa da war
doch mal was ja was erzählen sie da die
wahrheit wie es war
naja das ins gefängnis kommen dass die
betrügereien gemacht habe und dass sich
der zug stand
wenn ich dazu nicht stehen kann bei
meiner kinder wenn sie einmal große
nämlich fragen dann habe ich was falsch
gemacht
ich glaube dass ein händler dann auch
verdient die die wahrheit zu erfahren
und drum herum zu reden
ja aber wenn sie sagen sie waren ein
lügner oder den hochstapler anderen
größenwahnsinnig alles von dem 3 also
hochstapler war nicht so falsch
ich sag mal von jedem wort das ist immer
dass seine neue rolle als familienvater
im hier und jetzt spiele das
wirklichkeit sei was fast wie ein
märchen klingt all das ist volker eckel
zu wünschen und seinen kindern ganz
besonders
[Musik]